attorney general merrick garland going
to bath for his boss today refusing to
give senators an update of the federal
investigation at the hunter biden that
as the a.g faces more pressure to
appoint a special counsel terrible idea
garland also insisting as the judge
looks at me with white eyes that
president biden has not meddled in that
ongoing probe of his son biden's hunter
biden's laundry list of shady business
dealings
there will not be interference of any
political or improper kind would you
think it would be appropriate for the
president of the united states to call
you into the oval office
and tell you that his son didn't break
the law
regarding this matter uh absolutely not
and uh the president has not done that
and the president has committed not to
interfere not only in that investigation
but any other kind of appropriate
while he muttering inappropriate he just
said it wouldn't be inappropriate for
the president to come into his office
and say my son didn't break the law
could you imagine if president trump did
that he went in and said to his attorney
general you know my son didn't break the
law not that his son was accused of it
let me tell you something there was
nothing more inappropriate than the
president's son being investigated by
someone an attorney general merrick
garland who has the ultimate say into
whether or not that boy is being that
that song is going to be about wait a
minute we the americans let's just let's
assume it's more than irs okay whether
we're talking money laundering or
talking pharah we are entitled to know
what the chinese the russians the
ukrainians and all these foreign
nationals believe they were buying in
money that these two are sharing biden
joe biden is paying for hunter's tax
bill
and
hunter is paying for the house bills and
there's nothing illegal for joe biden to
say yeah i discussed my son's business
what's the problem unless they're
worried about what the business is
that's all
dana special prosecutors are a horrible
idea they are a construct a washington
construct that gives work to out-of-work
uh lawyers in d.c
they have the life of their own because
people don't want to disband them
because it's their job
look at robert mueller i mean russia
russia how are we going to live through
this again well i think that as i
understand it there is no allegation
that the u.s attorney in delaware has
done anything inappropriate here and he
has the federal grand jury that's
underway
and we know that because there were
there's been leaks and i think that was
because the left was hearing that there
could be a problem so i i don't think
the u.s attorney has done anything wrong
there if there should be a special
counsel i gotta tell you it's a little
bit above my pay grade i don't i don't
know but i don't necessarily think so at
the moment one concern might be if you
go to a if you all of a sudden say okay
now we need a special counsel that
person then can say well i got to start
over in the investigation and how long
would that take do you understand that
the attorney general has the final
say-so as to whether a public official
is indicted it's not just the u.s
attorney in delaware i do understand but
the fact of the matter is
the u.s attorney in delaware is
investigating hunter biden he has the
grand jury just as durham is
investigating uh you know the origins of
russia russia russia and the hillary
clinton and the sussman and all that
stuff special counsels
absolutely accomplished nothing other
than giving people employment
hunter binds a bad scuzzy
creepy
etc cetera but that doesn't why should
that reflect badly on his parents
well because of the business deals with
joe
and you know better than anybody geraldo
the president lied he went out there and
he said a thousand times doesn't discuss
business with his son and we could name
like 20 things right now where that's a
stone cold lie they had a document just
released the other day where joe agreed
to pay 700 g's 800. 800 g's glad you
read it
to cover hunter's legal fees for the
china deal and then it turns out this is
what doesn't make any sense
so joe after he leaves the white house
in 2016 2017 he releases his financials
so he has four years to make some money
so we made about 17 million 14 million
in four years
how do you do that harald that was book
bombed biggest advance you'd get maybe
five million as dana tells you
beaches no one wants 250 000
minimum
okay so you give a few speeches that's
five million there's a seven million
dollar or five million dollars
has never ever been accused
the money was income from his wife's
bustling medical practice he is a doctor
you know
it is not illegal to pay your kids bills
and it's not illegal to have more things
some
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else